ganz am anfang der pandemie hat das team
von professor drosten an der berliner
charité den ersten zuverlässigen test
pcr test entwickelt der die krankheit
nachwies er kennt die codes des virus
guten abend nach berlin guten abend herr
kleber ich weiß wir wissen noch nicht so
arg viel aber nach allem was berichtet
wird auch von fachkollegen und nach den
hinweisen sie sie bekommen kann diese
omikron variante die sache noch einmal
deutlich schlimmer machen ja leider also
wir wissen tatsächlich nicht allzu viel
darüber ich bin schon ziemlich besorgt
im moment muss ich sagen ich bin
überrascht so viele mutationen in diesem
virus zu sehen das ist dann allerdings
auch das einzige was wirklich greifbar
ist diese mutationen und man versteht
nicht immer gleich was mutationen dann
im echten leben machen es gibt ja heute
in den medien berichte über milde
verläufe ich finde daran ist noch nicht
sehr viel substanz wir haben gerade mal
etwas über 1000 fälle überhaupt
nachgewiesen und deren klinischen
verlauf muss man erst mal sehen
das heißt man muss da wirklich für alles
offen sein was man schon sagen kann ist
dass diese infektion hier sehr häufig
bei jungen leuten auftritt in südafrika
bei leuten die in aller erster linie
dieser erkrankung auch schon hinter sich
haben das jetzt als zweite oder sogar
dritte infektion bekommen und dann eben
auch wieder mit symptomen keiner kann im
moment sagen was da auf uns zukommt das
einzige was man glaube ich wirklich mit
sicherheit sagen kann ist es ist besser
wenn man geimpft ist es noch besser wenn
man gewusst hat ist nun ist es ja so
dass jemand der bisher als genesen gilt
schon als ähnlich oder vielleicht sogar
besser geschützt als durch die impfung
galt wenn sie jetzt sagen in südafrika
erkrankten menschen die schon richtig
cupid hatten dann spricht das dafür dass
jedenfalls dieser schutz unterlaufen
werden könnte das ist genau die sorge
dass wir hier eben jetzt eine erste
wirkliche immun escape also immun flucht
mutante vor uns haben die anderen
mutanten bisher hatten diese eigenschaft
noch nicht so stark und
alle sind natürlich da auch ein bisschen
nervös und gespannt ob man
möglicherweise so viel schutz verliert
sowohl durch die überstandenen infektion
wie hoffentlich nicht durch die
impfungen dass man sogar die impfungen
noch mal verändern müsste alles das
werden sicherlich die nächsten zwei bis
drei wochen beantworten wir müssen auch
verstehen wie es jetzt wirklich mit der
krankheit schwere ist und was wir im
moment noch gar nicht sagen können ist
wie sich das bei uns verhält denn hier
hat das virus andere bedingungen als in
südafrika bei uns sind viele menschen
geimpft eben nicht genesen und das ist
ein unterschied
und in unserer bevölkerung müssen wir
eben auch ganz genau hinschauen und muss
auch sagen es gibt eben schon immer mehr
meldungen die ich so rein bekomme aus
dem kollegen kollegenkreis dass es doch
schon einiges an infektionen gibt in
deutschland und in europa das klingt
doch ein bisschen anders als die ersten
stellungnahmen von fachleuten gestern
allerdings haben die ja auch immer dazu
gesagt wir können noch ganz wenig sagen
aber ich spüre jetzt ein bisschen andere
tonalität in ihrer auskunft genau also
es ist tatsächlich eine situation die
sich von tag zu tag weiter entwickelt
und momentan wissen wir nicht was da auf
uns zukommt
es fühlt sich aber anders an als die
ersten informationen bei der alpha und
der delta variante darum finde ich wir
sollten das jetzt lieber ernst nehmen
wenn sich dann doch zeigen sollte dass
hier beispielsweise die symptome schwere
abgemildert ist dann können wir alle
ziemlich erleichtert sein aber ich bin
da sehr weit im moment davon weg von
dieser auffassung wird man denn
zuverlässig darauf zählen können dass es
gelingen wird die impfstoffe wieder
anzupassen das soll ja gerade der große
vorteil dieser modernen impf technik
sein dass man solche mutationen wieder
einfangen kann ja das ist richtig das
wird man technisch relativ einfach
machen können und auch regulativ ist
dieser weg vorgeformt aber wir sprechen
hier doch von monaten bis von mehreren
monaten bis da die ersten dosen wirklich
ausgeliefert werden und dann müssen ja
wirklich größere zahlen produziert
werden das ist also gar nicht dass akute
aktuelle problem wir müssen jetzt mit
den verfügbaren impfstoffen die
gegen den schweren verlauf mit wirklich
sehr sehr großer wahrscheinlichkeit
schützen werden egal ob diese variante
jetzt für die übertragbarkeit
sagen wir mal besser zugänglich ist
wir müssen jetzt sehen dass wir zwei
dinge machen wir müssen boostern so
schnell ist irgend geht denn unser
eigentliches problem ist ja weiter die
delta variante die winter welle die wir
jetzt haben dagegen ist also die omikron
variante die jetzt aus südafrika kommt
ein mini problem im moment und wir
müssen die impflücken schließen
unbedingt das ist ganz entscheidend denn
wenn man gar nicht geschützt ist möchte
man auch die omikron variante nicht
nicht treffen nun kommen wir mal auf das
aktuelle problem dass wir auch ohne
omikron hätten die leopoldina die
nationale akademie der wissenschaften
hat unter ihrer beteiligung gestern ein
brandbrief geschrieben dass sofort was
passieren müsste der wahrscheinlich
nächste kanzler hat in den letzten tagen
gesagt nur warten wir doch mal ab wir
haben doch gerade eben verschärfungen
beschlossen 3g an den arbeitsplätzen
zweig in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
große appelle von allen seiten doch zur
impfung zu gehen und abstand zu halten
vielleicht greift das ja warum drängen
sie so auf 23 4 tage naja es ist im
moment ja besorgniserregend was man in
einigen bundesländern schon auf den
intensivstationen sieht ich glaube das
müssen wir jetzt hier nicht ausführen
das ist ja teil der berichterstattung
wir haben einfach eine etwas unwägbare
situation diese codes 2g 3g mit denen
hat man eigentlich keine erfahrung
bisher gemacht in einer wirklichen
winter welle wir haben hier ja eine
differenzierung geimpft versus ungeimpft
während wir aber genau so gar nicht
wissen wie denn die übertragung direkt
übertragung durch die geimpften ist das
muss man also alles annehmen und im
moment ist das eine situation wie kann
kaum noch jemand modellieren und
gleichzeitig sehen wir dass die
infektionszahlen doch relativ
unbeeindruckt sind von der ganzen sache
von diesen 2 oder 3 gs die man da
beendet und ich glaube das ist das
wichtigste was man jetzt im moment auch
wirklich der politik empfehlen kann ganz
genau hinzuschauen den gebieten
beispielsweise österreich sachsen bayern
wo schon in verschärftem maße diese
maßnahmen jetzt angewandt werden wo also
großveranstaltungen schon abgesagt
werden und dann man sich eben auf dieses
klein management gfs ungeimpft wer darf
an einer veranstaltung teilnehmen wo man
sich ja dass das aktiv gemacht hat und
wo man jetzt so langsam anfangen kann
effekte zu sehen also in bayern
beispielsweise geht der er wird langsam
ein bisschen runter gegen eins wir
müssen aber auf 0,7 kommen um wirklich
in absehbarer zeit die fallzahl so
runter zu bekommen dass eine entspannung
auf der intensivstation möglich ist und
da sind wir schon ziemlich weit von
entfernt noch sie haben in diesem brief
an die verantwortlichen geschrieben ist
müsste sofort anfang nächster woche
inzwischen ist sonntag also ab morgen
müsste energisches passieren danach
schießt es zu dieser stunde jetzt aber
nicht aus was passiert denn wenn nichts
passiert außer dass man nach kräften die
impfungen hochfährt was ist dann die
zeit bis weihnachten was steht uns bevor
naja ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das
verimpft der booster dosen schnell genug
gehen kann also in israel war die
erfahrung dass man die halbe bevölkerung
mit einem booster versorgt hatte und
dann gegen die inzidenz doch merklich
runter davon sind wir weit entfernt wir
haben ungefähr acht millionen gewusst
hat die hälfte unserer bevölkerung
werden über 40 millionen das ist also
bis weihnachten nicht zu schaffen und
das ist die große sorge eigentlich dass
wir dann eben das reale problem bekommen
in der intensivmedizin dass wir einfach
nicht mehr die betten haben man könnte
auch ein paar positive nachrichten dazu
geben es ist tatsächlich im moment so
dass wir ein etwas absinken der
krankheit schwere sehen das heißt es
müssen nicht mehr wie noch vor ein paar
monaten so ein prozent der infizierten
beatmet werden sondern das geht jetzt so
auf 0,7 prozent 0,6 prozent vielleicht
und weiter sinkend kommt sicher daher
das jetzt eben die booster impfungen so
langsam greifen aber dieser prozess wird
wahrscheinlich schleppend sein dieses
entkoppeln der krankheit schwere und die
leute kommen weiter auf die
intensivstation und das ist schrecklich
also hängt alles davon ab was in den
nächsten tagen politisch entschieden
wird oder eben nicht danke für das
gespräch professor thorsten sehr gern